bởi vì tháng biểu tại lấy khai trường, thu tướng và mấy trình nhấn mạnh Việt Nam và cambu trường
là hai nước lắng dường gần gũi, xong nguy lần kè, cùng thuộc vùng hả Liu Xong May Công,
xuất sáo thập kỳ quan hệ lắng dường tún đẹp, thữ nghĩ chuyên thống,
thật tác toàn dịt, bên bựng lâu dài Việt Nam cambu trường,
đã kinh định nước quan nhiều thứ thách,
và ngay càng được quân đáp cùng cố phát triển thông gần.
Hãy hình dân Việt Nam và cambu trường,
giám nhau nhé em lắng dường đánh mó, cùng chiến họt, sẻ mùi,
lọc trước đây, cũng như quái trình xây dựng và phát triển hai đất nước này này,
cũng tưởng bày tỏ vui mừng khi những năm gần đây,
quan hệ Việt Nam cambu trường tích tục đà phát triển mạnh mẽ,
thức chất, kể quả triển tất cả lệ vực.
Đặc biệt, hợp tắc kinh tế thương mại,
đồ tư phát triển án dựng,
trong đó thương mại viên dưới là điểm sáng nửa vật,
các cửh khẩu cú tế, giọc tiến viên dưới Việt Nam cambu trường.
Nóng vai trọc quan trọng trong khi nối 2 này tình tế,
kinh ngày thương mại sông phương nghiệm năm gần đây,
muốn được suy chi bình quân khoảng 1 tí đồ làm Mỹ 1 năm,
và giữ kiến cả năm, hình phu trọng hay lâm,
có thể đặt 12 tí đồ làm Mỹ.
Tụi tưởng cho rằng,
lế khánh thành kơi khẩu phức tế năm tân miếng trây hôm nay,
thiển gió tình thình tin cầy, đoàn két,
hình tắt chạp chế và hiệu quả giữa hai chính cụ Việt Nam và càm bu chiếm.
Rồi đó, hay bên cân par vi hơn nữa,
ý thức chất nhợ, đồ về việc giữa dịt,
chất tự ăn nền ở biến dưới,
ra ra và vùng ngập tắt kiểu mẫu giữa hai nước,
để cụ khẩu tân năm,
mình trời đi vào hả động thương xuất,
hiệu quả khủ tướng nền bị cách bộ ngày,
cụ quan và địa phương liên quan của hai nước,
tí tục phối ở chặt chế,
tập chung vào năm tăng kương,
ngôm tăng kưởng phối ở chặt chế hơn nữa,
về còn li bên dưới,
tăng kưởng đứng dạng hã thuộc,
số hã thuộc quan,
xây dựng cụ khẩu thông mình,
tăng kưởng khích đúng hả tần và phương ra kích tế biến mẫu,
tăng kưởng liên kích bồ,
đặc biệt giữa tính tay nình và pray biến.
Tăng kưởng bay chào vánh nghiệp,
vụi nghe hàng giữa hai nước,
hụi tưởng nhắc câu tục gửi của Việt Nam,
ra hả thương mở lối,
tí tượng mở đường,
và tính tưởng cụ khẩu tân năm,
sẽ trở thành một hình mẫu cụ khẩu,
phút tế đi đầu trong phía đường số,
thông mình, bánh mình, hiện nay,
mang lại sự tí tưởng gửi ở nó,
hảnh phút trong nghe danh,
đưa vùng biến giới Việt Nam,
cảm buồn chia khu xửi trở thành vàng đại anh nền,
yp cầu hiệu nghỉ,
đậu lực tăng trường,
diểm tửa lòng rân của hai nước,
và có phần cùng của mối trường hoa bên,
ông định,
thông cắt và phát triển nhàng,
mình vợi trong của bật.
Về phía mình,
thu tưởng vân cuông cầm buồn chia của màn đẹp,
lẽ khán thành chính thức nưa vào vận hành
cơ khẩu quốc tế tên năm,
mừng trời,
là mình trưởng chào thay sự mặt thiết,
trong mỗi quan hệ hợp tắt,
rửa khám buồn chia và biến Nam,
quan đó,
đã có phần biến khu vực biến dưới hai nước,
trở thành biến dưới hoa bên,
orn định,
biến dưới dành cho sự rao thương chào đợi hành hoa,
dịch vụ và biến dưới của sự phát triển,
thu tụi chọn của sống của nhân dân hai nước,
cũng tiến thu tụi cầm buồn chia của màn đẹp,
cũng quyền thích các vộ,
mang ngành liên quan của hai nước,
xúc tiến chào đổi,
đưa các cập kêu khẩu quốc tế tên năm,
mừng trời và trong dành xách thử cầu biến dưới,
phù hợp với giúp định về hành hoa ám rạc khó cạnh,
và đưa các cập kêu khẩu đàn và trong y đến dư,
để chiến khai thức giữa giúp định về bản thẩy được bộ.